i'm back with a very important video on
how to stop frying your brain
with your cell phone now i've talked
about this in other videos but i wanted
to
do a series of videos on something
called emf
and try to break it down really really
simple it's going to be a fairly short
video but i'm going to show you
what i do to minimize what's called
invisible radiation
so emf what is it it stands for
electromagnetic
field so what does that mean well you
have an electric
component to it you have a magnetic
field
part of it and you also have other
fields of energy
radio frequencies and even microwaves
typically you think of microwaves being
the microwave oven
but there's other things that will give
you microwaves
including your cell phone the problem is
it's not regulated
by safety codes at this time so it's
kind of like
at some point in time people started
smoking and smoking was considered
actually beneficial for you you also had
ddt
which was considered beneficial you also
had asbestos
which was considered safe and then you
had sugar which was considered
beneficial at one time
and then years later they found out oh
we didn't do the safety testing on that
long enough so
whoops sorry so we're going to put some
regulation in so right now
unfortunately there's not a lot of
safety testing going on
now let's first talk about the
electrical fields so you have
all these little electrons going through
a wire that's called
the current going through the wire and
the pressure that's pushing
this electricity is called the voltage
so it's the pressure from a power source
so the more pressure or more
voltage the more electrical field you're
going to have on the wire
and so let's say for example you're
trying to sleep at night and
right next to your bed you have
a light source you have your alarm clock
you have some other electrical devices
and some people might have the
consideration that if they turn the
light off
the electrical field goes away
well i want to demonstrate that it
actually doesn't go away unless
you unplug the light at the outlet
on your wall because even though you
turn
the light off at this level if you were
to open up this
wire it would be hot or live
in other words there's voltage in that
wire
that is generating an electrical field
unless you disconnect it
at the wall and so there's different
switches that you can get you can plug
it into the wall
and then plug your uh light into there
so you can turn things off
at the outlet level so there'll be less
electrical current coming from
these wires next to your head while
you're sleeping
and then you have magnetic fields so
magnetic field occurs anytime there's
current flowing through a wire and so
there's a field that's generated
sometimes six to eight feet from
that source if it's a strong magnetic
field and so magnetic fields only occur
if it's live if there's current flowing
through a wire so let me demonstrate
that
so i'm on electrical fields right here
and take a look at these wires down here
right these wires
are connecting to this light right here
okay now
let's go ahead and turn off the light
okay
look it this is still high
the wire is still high because there's
voltage
in this cord so we want to turn it off
at the outlet or just unplug the light
or other devices
next to your bed okay for the next
demonstration
i'm going to turn it to magnetic fields
in order for something to have a
magnetic field
you have to have current flowing through
it so we turned on the light
okay so we have the light right through
here
you can see that it's pretty high right
now i'm gonna turn off the light
[Music]
okay now i'm gonna i'm gonna assess the
the same cord
and it's not not very active if at all
why because the magnetic field only
occurs if there's
current flowing through the wire if i
turn it to the electrical field
it's high but not magnetic
so electrical fields have to do with
voltage which is the power
that's pushing these little electrons
and magnetic field has to do with the
fields that extend beyond the current
it's not the voltage or the power
it's just the electrons going through it
and then we get to something called
radio waves or microwaves
and for that topic you have a router you
might have
a cell tower that is sending signals to
your cell phone
and so if your phone is close to your
head your brain
you're going to be getting exposure to
microwaves not to mention maybe some
magnetic
and electrical fields as well so let me
do a little demonstration with the cell
phone to show you
all right so now we're going to turn
this all the way to radio
frequencies okay i'm going to get it
close to my cell phone right here you
can see it's pulsing right because we
have this
this uh the cell tower is sending
signals every so often
okay so now i'm going to actually make a
call
i'm going to call jared
[Music]
so you can you can see that it's pulsing
like this so all this
microwaves are going right to your brain
if it's held up
close to your skull now in the future
i'm going to do some other videos to
show you how to identify
other sources of invisible
radiation using this tool right here i
like the tri-field
emf meter model tf2
i have other devices this seems to be
very simple it's very accurate
and i'm going to show you what i found
with my power cables my up on my
computer
the actual screen itself the wi-fi
devices
the printer and so all these things are
bathing your body
in these frequencies and if you're
sitting behind the computer
like i do for a very long time um it's
not healthy so you're gonna have to
minimize the exposure and
find out where it's coming from so with
this device you can measure
the radio frequencies the electrical
fields
as well as the magnetic fields very very
simply and
i'll be doing more videos on that if
you're interested in getting one of
these
i'll put a link down below and you can
check it out i don't get any kickbacks
or anything like that
and so it's a really good device and you
can go around your house and just find
the sources
of uh where you're being affected now
getting back to the cell phone
what are you gonna do well there's a
couple things first thing is that uh try
to talk with the speaker on
so it's not connected to your head
but what i found was this right here
okay so now i have these earbuds
which are right here right got it
plugged into my phone
and i still have it on radiation
so you can see that they're not really
having any effect definitely earbuds are
the way to go
so we have earphones and a mic and it's
called
anti-radiation air tubes okay they're
headphones with the mic
emf protection you can look these up
i'll put a link down below
on amazon um on the one that i have
but again i don't get any kickbacks or
any commissions but i just want you guys
to know about this so
what's cool about this is that there's
just a tube
between this source and your ear so it
gives you some
space so you don't have a direct
electrical wire going into your ear
that's why i don't recommend the
bluetooth devices where you're sticking
the ear
now the sound pickup is not perfect but
it's doable
so what you do is you would put these in
your ear
and the problem is that this is not
going to connect into your cell phone
okay so you have to get an adapter and
so i got an adapter right here
i'll put a link down below which plugs
into this 3.5 millimeter jack
then i can stick this into my cell phone
so now i can hold
the source of the radiation over here
and not have it affect my brain now i am
doing a lot of zoom presentations
all day long so what i did is i got an
adapter for that
too so this is what it looks like right
here so this has a usb
and then i can plug this right here
plug this in the back of my computer and
now i can actually be on zoom
and interact with people and so no
longer do i have to have those
headphones
which actually make your head so tired
and so i found my energy greatly
increased after getting
these this adapter and also these
earphones so i highly recommend it if
you're on the phone a lot i would
recommend it for your kids if they're on
zoom
doing the home school especially the
younger they are the more sensitive
they're going to be especially on
putting electromagnetic fields into your
brain not a good thing
so go ahead and try this and comment
down below and
stay tuned for more information about
how to
protect yourself against emfs
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto and you need a debug
because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help